dating me while i'm filming a reality
show every like every day i had like
four story lines everyone had a comment
he was like so nice to everyone he
leaves and then someone was like yeah he
didn't hang out with the group enough he
was there for two days and i know it's
like a story line they're doing but i
know that they're going to edit it like
he's like he's now with people
especially when he's literally doing a
flavor for the show what the [ __ ] is
going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sister we just become
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite favorite favorite
sisters fia and
sistine
oh you know when your nail polish is
just completely
it off i know i'm not gonna lie it
brings your number down a notch yeah
easily it's not cute it's not a good
look you just look dirty well you know
what i feel like i'm the only person
left that doesn't do gels i'd use
regular polish and i forget every time i
put it on i'm like oh why don't i just
continue to use regular polish i don't
need y'all it chips in two seconds well
that's why you just kind of it's risk
having [ __ ] up nails forever as long
as they look good and you know what's
interesting about wearing nail polish
people don't actually notice it until
you have
a fresh set of clothes on guys really do
care about clean nails they're like
white white nails it's white toes and
white nails is like a thing that they
love but yeah i mean at least one thing
i have seen is my nails are getting a
lot healthier and stronger without doing
gels a ton all right which is good so i
don't need to put like
fake nails on which is yeah that's what
i do and honestly if i were to remove
them right now i think they would
look like saran wrap under there that's
how thin they are they were like that
for me when i first took them off and
obviously this is an interesting thing i
don't care about right now i don't care
they look good um sofia are a little bit
delusional as you could tell from our
intro right there
uh we just got back to la we were in new
york it was a very spontaneous last
minute trip you know last time we were
there shooting the podcast i vowed to
myself i would never come back and there
i found myself two weeks later that was
it was not hard to convince her to go
yeah you know what every time i go to
the city i have this expectation that
i'm gonna have the greatest time i have
this whole bucket list of things i want
to do i actually made a checklist of
everything that i wanted to hit in new
york i wanted to do something really
cheesy touristy i wanted to go to
central park zoo eat a street hot dog do
all this kind of stuff go to a museum
i didn't
tick one thing off my list
and that's the problem with new york you
just end up walking way too much and
then you're pooped by the time you get
to dinner yeah you really don't realize
you've walked 15 000 steps within the
hour and then you just don't want to
move i mean at least you know at least
you don't work out
that yeah that's true i feel like i'm
almost compensating for the pasta i eat
every single night yeah but i definitely
you know
is it true when you go on vacation that
just calories don't count i feel like
i'm [ __ ] i i go on these trips to new
york or wherever it is and i just
normally my routine is like i'll eat
very healthy
and then i go i'm like no you know what
like i could totally have an egg
mcmuffin for breakfast lunch and dinner
live your life
you know what we're so hard on ourselves
when we're in l.a in terms of
it's not we restrict it's just we like
to eat really clean and healthy yeah for
what nothing we have nothing coming up i
don't know why we yeah i'm gonna torture
ourselves oh it's illustrated or
anything that would be nice thank you
reach out to us let us know
you know we did submit but wait did we
sweat
no response yet but looking optimistic
for next year uh and by the time we get
to you know new york or we're traveling
like you said
it's like we
look at
dessert
as if we've never tasted sugar before
yeah and we inhale it we don't eat it
like really cute oh i'm good after two
bites we're like can i have yours no
really even my boyfriend would say like
he's like i just love that you just you
eat and i'm like like you just haven't
like you don't just like hold back on
because i'm like i know because i don't
have i have absolutely no restraint when
it comes to food i'm one of those people
i actually can't have i mean some people
can relate to this
if there's a carton of ice cream in my
apartment yeah i'm not that person that
can just have like one bite and wait two
days for carton yeah i mean look indulge
do whatever you want if you want that
ice cream go at it but for me i
genuinely cannot
with like withhold myself from eating
all the desserts in my apartment well
see i have a really bad habit if if i
have a plate of food and i have at least
like four bites left and i'm stuffed
like i can't eat any more i don't know
if it's my ocd i'm like i just have to
finish it like and then i'm really
feeling sick after like i didn't have to
i was satisfied right now but i just
yeah anyway the food was great the food
was great but you know what we realized
and every single time
we travel we make the same comment is
that
just just this alone people at the
airport
do they just become
i know
everyone forgets how to do things
there's something called i believe
airport brain yeah and everyone just
loses one loses a brain loses a brain
when they enter those the cells are gone
the brain cells just disappear and it's
for one thing can i just say wear socks
wear socks you know you're gonna go
through tsa don't walk on barefoot
actually have a bone to pick with tsa i
appreciate the work you guys do you know
keeping us all safe
but
why do i always go off i'm always
getting a pat down i walked in on the
way to new york through the little body
scanner
i'm wearing a hoodie and a tank top i'm
not wearing an underwire bra because us
ladies know that sometimes that'll set
it off not wearing jewelry i'm wearing
sweats a tank top and socks
now tell me how my bosom area is always
going on
everything's serious i don't have any
jewelry over there i'm really confused
and they're like oh this lady has to pat
you down so then i'm getting groped at 8
30 in the morning at lax no you met
human touch isn't a bad thing i'm not
complaining but you know at 8 30 buy a
lady with some gloves on not loving it
not the touch you want you're like no i
like physical touch for five languages
just not from tsa i actually did that
one time and drank before a flight and
went to the hotel not the hotel the
airport bar well i felt really fancy i
don't know why you feel do you feel
sophisticated like i could handle my
life bringing a book to a restaurant or
eating a lot it's just kind of like i am
the main character am i going to have
this like little meat cube am i the air
bar having a mojito maybe that bar yeah
maybe that's a way to meet people but
the people also have airport brain
so then that's true someone said
actually i saw this on tick tock this
woman was like do you want to meet
eligible men that have money
you must buy a ticket you don't need to
go on the plane and go to the delta
lounge or the american airlines lounge
where it's like the first class lounge
right and then you just sit at the bar
there okay so just
wait and then she goes you'll meet the
greatest guy asking people to spend two
thousand dollars on a first class ticket
just to sit in an airport lounge now see
i'm not sitting in the lounge i'm
sitting in like the general public area
and let me tell you those those chaps
are interesting yeah there's some
interesting i feel like do you feel like
you're stared at
when you're walking through the airport
sometimes like people are just like
evaluating you no but i think i'm
walking through a high school hallway
sometimes
i think that we walk around and we're
like are you looking at me because we
actually think people are saying they're
like no we're looking through you
actually yeah i think they're just
looking at us because they don't know
what else to look at no i think that's
our main character complex thinking that
everyone's looking is that my ego yes
and no one's looking at us all right so
no one's looking at me i'm just
delusional i want to talk about um
the wonderful birthday present you had
planned for me okay um okay okay so we
talked about this last week and i was so
excited because oh there goes my dress
um
i had planned for sistine earlier
because her birthday um came around
later on but i wanted to book her pretty
woman because we love musicals and love
she loves the movie and i was stoked i'm
like this was on broadway they're
bringing it to la
why not let's go to a fun restaurant and
then go to the play yeah the reservation
was cool yeah the views were awesome the
food was good and then we hopped over to
the place
i was at the dolby theater yeah
for one thing we were
the most dressed up i thought it was i
thought you were supposed to dress up
and i were like we're going to the
theater
dress in heels and everyone was in like
crop tacky and like khakis yeah like
socks and sandals damn it i know come on
guys put on a suit go to the theater
maybe people will do that in new york
but in l.a it's on hollywood boulevard
there's a man and then there's
jack sparrow next no one's dressing up
so we sit down and we're so excited but
we're the first people by the way
sitting there there's no one there ever
the first blasted cold air on the back
of our necks we're sitting right under
the air vent and it was at least 50
degrees
i have never
in my entire life
hated a play
more
and i just want to just say this really
quick so then people don't come at me
i give total credit to the actors and
the production i know artists put on a
musical and the writing and everything
the music it's hard i'm not
i'm not belittling that i'm just saying
the way you guys made the film
look as a musical it's a scene you
cannot go
is it true
it's true let me give you my pov we're
sitting there the curtain raises we are
like oh here we go it's showtime you
know
the first number starts
and i'm biting my bottom lip because i'm
like
surely it must get better from here
and this can't be the whole you know
attitude theme of the film
which by the way it's true they
completely changed everything the story
of pretty woman which is sad because
it's one of my favorite films
and i look over at sophia i give her
side x again like she had planned this
whole night for me i didn't want to seem
ungrateful but i was like it's pretty
[ __ ] bad it's pretty bad and i look
at her and she gives me this dead eye
and she's like
we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
we gotta go we gotta go after the third
song
i realized and also look i might the
actors were great but you guys casted
that
fully wrong
i would say i would say the guy that
played the um hotel manager was awesome
the baja was great like all of them were
awesome just the leads there was no
connection between the two main
characters you know she's playing a
prostitute he's a a wealthy businessman
they looked like they wouldn't touch
each other with the 10-foot pole but it
wasn't and the the guy that was supposed
to play richard gere wasn't like this
brooding kind of sexy quiet
but he was just like more i don't know
it was it just wasn't as it wasn't the
same and the music wasn't that good the
everyone did an amazing job performance
wise in terms of like executing it but
it's just our cup of tea maybe you loved
it and maybe we're totally wrong so we i
was i started leaving sprint out of
there when intermission intermission we
counted down how many more songs there
were i'm actually shocked you said
intermission because you kept calling it
half time
i couldn't even think i was so annoyed
yeah i was so frustrated because i'm so
excited we get out of there and we call
an uber we're like all right sophia this
is a good attempt we're gonna call it a
night
all of a sudden we see iron man
iron man on the street he was like
hello ladies we were like hello iron man
wow
cool he has these like little lights
and we're we're trying to walk past and
be standing literally right in front of
the uber and these four kids come up to
him and they started no no first they
come up to me and these four gen zers
and they have these like long shaggy
hairs like hey you want to be in our
tick tock and i was like absolutely not
they go to iron man yeah and they kind
of start messing with
they were touching his suit and then he
got a little bit more aggressive they
started pushing him and punching his
suit and the guy was like hey hey guys
stop stop doing that and the kids kept
doing it they're like oh you don't like
that iron man i just kept egging him on
so the guy
lifts up his
face masks and looks directly in the
case he goes yeah we're gonna have a
problem and like they were gonna fight
they were sizing each other up iron man
against these four tick talkers you're
not gonna win iron man is obviously
gonna win yeah this guy was pissed and
all of this was happening in front of
our car they were essentially blocking
it like we could not get into our car
and i was like you know what that was
the cherry on top of this excellent
birthday and i got in the car and i
looked at sistine i said happy birthday
muzzle mazel that was speaking of tick
tock i am
so in love with this trend that's coming
around and i feel like cece and i just
are obsessed with these type of trends i
love trends it's he's a 10 butt so if
you don't know what the premise is is
basically and guys do it too so i'm not
just saying oh it's only guys and girls
but you basically rank a guy you say oh
he's a 10 out of 10 like he's perfect
but he has bad breath and so what is his
ranking now so you'd say oh it's a two
because bad breath sucks so we wanted to
do a little bit of it why don't you
start us off
okay
scared um
he's an eight
but he constantly talks about how
awesome his college and frat life was
like my time at princeton was just so
good i would say seven it's not a deal
breaker could it get repetitive yeah but
he was proud of it you know he like he
went to college and he has a lot of
memories look you spend four years of
your young adult life there that's a lot
you know okay that's i thought you're
gonna stay lower i don't know um all
right
we'll say he's
and
he's a nine but has no idea how to dress
like what does he wear she's just like
ugly horrible outfits
stuff that he may be like he's
nine maybe like a sheer top
i don't know he's a six i care about i
care about it i care about it that would
go away because if he had good style and
he was a six i'd say he's nate
i got another thing that's like a trap
he's
a 10 but has really dirty fingernails
seven
oh okay he's a 6.5 but you're sitting
next to him on a flight oh an eight
point five yeah i feel like everyone's
okay i got one he's a four but
he's in the nfl
he's easily straight up in eight
okay um
he's a uh
he's a three um but his favorite movie
is ratatouille
eleven
it's your you know this is my red flag
he's a ten but his favorite movie is
wolff of wall street oh and what do we
always say
that's a zero zero that's a zero no i
just love those times but people have
been going off on them and they do it
with girls too and it's just so bobby do
you have one he's a seven but he's your
ex-boyfriend he's a seven but he's your
ex-boyfriend
really
i'm gonna say he's a nine you can't see
that
no
no no
okay okay okay um
he's
he's a nine
but he calls his mom every day
it's very subjective
okay sweet he's a six he has no interest
in you he's a six but has no interest in
you oh that's a 10 for me because i
can't it's like uh
it's like
if someone doesn't answer me i always go
how about you love me come on he's a
nine but
has almost too much interest in you
he's a four
no nice and nine
no you would never go in for guys
if a nine was showing interest to me uh
he stays a nine a ten
too much though to the point where like
why does he show this much attention
eight maybe
i still like the attention
should we do them for girls oh yeah for
girls
she's a seven but she still has like
2014 ombre
you know i mean like really orange
she's a nine but she was the present of
her sorority oh
that's a four
they're crazy i have friends or presents
you're a ten can't see this
she's an ape but she's a hot cheeto girl
i don't even know what that means like
is always eating like hot cheetos and
it's all over her hands i'm still an
eight oh oliver yeah like gross is that
just like your personality she's walking
with hot cheeto hands nevermind you guys
don't get it scarlett would get it if
she was here
thank you oh god okay okay okay whatever
last year you said make them 10.
10.
you're like a hot cheeto girl yeah
whoa i got to buy some hot cheetos
oh my god uh how about this he's
a five but he is um subscribed to the
unwaxed podcast oh it's a
friggin 15 out of 10. that's a 10. wait
hold on
she's in a nine okay but she drunk calls
and cries every time she gets drunk oh
like a three here
that's actually a thing like they hate
that yeah more or less she's
an 8 but she purposely never answers
texts or calls and she oh that's what
makes that our personalities i never
answered about he's a nine but he sleeps
with socks on is that weird i don't know
mine sucks seven that's seven okay okay
i see my socks on he's at nine but
you're fat
[Laughter]
yeah we do each other's backs okay okay
let's talk about the amazing guest we
have on today i'm actually really
excited i think i want to talk before
she gets in the room i'm a massive fan
of hers and i've been following her and
her work and her comedy and her podcast
for a very long time you know what
[ __ ] i'm going to say it to her face
i love her i'm so excited i think this
conversation is going to be hysterical
yeah so stay tuned for that
[Music]
today we have on the funniest person to
appear on the unwax podcast starting her
young career as a professional tennis
player this multi-talented woman has
become a very successful stand-up
comedian frequently performing at new
york city's iconic comedy seller she's
also a standout on the reality tv show
summer house love
and is the host of not one but two
podcasts this is the iconic hannah
berner studio audience
[Applause]
i paid them to say all these things
about me thank you so much of course
what an honor isn't that kind of cool to
listen to yourself like how many things
you've actually done you're like wait
it's kind of cool yeah it's weird
because you're so in your own head all
the time about who you are and then to
see how other people might view you 100
yeah it's kind of like when you think
everyone's mad at you and then someone's
like hey i think you're awesome and
you're like oh i made that up yeah yeah
you think everyone or you think someone
doesn't like you and the whole time they
just have a wrestling [ __ ] face you
know you know this person
you don't do enough or you haven't done
enough and you're like no no you're
doing a lot like
today i came from therapy and i was we
were like trying to talk about is it ego
that like i want to do more [ __ ] or is
it just because i love creating and it's
like a thin line what did you come up
with well because i was like i want to
put out a special but like people are
very like you know if you wait a little
longer it could potentially be better
but i'm also like if i waited around to
do [ __ ] in the past people would have
thought i was crazy like yeah just
starting to do comedy i was doing an
hour very early into my career which
most people be like right it's risky
don't do that right but i'm like i'm
more of a doer and and [ __ ] up 100 then
just like be stuck in my own i like that
you said that because i feel like that's
constantly even for your i think you too
like we're always being told like no
just wait like a year oh yeah just wait
you're not ready you're not ready that's
so not [ __ ] true you're [ __ ] right
especially with creative [ __ ] yeah and
also for women in general they say that
women like to take jobs they're
overqualified for and men take jobs
they're under-qualified for oh tea and
even with like dating i feel like girls
take guys they're over qualified
and like teach them life yeah and then
guys get these girls and i said hahaha
no we're swapping with chilling
i always like dating guys who are hotter
than me i like dating people who are
smarter than why not which is hard to
find because i'm a genius just kidding
and nobody probably is you want to
respect their
yeah and then i also always go for jobs
i
should not be hired for
but that's i think that's really
important also because you're
challenging yourself you want to do
better and you also want to even date
people that make you better we actually
have this conversation in new york and
we're like why do we not even like i'm
not saying in our relationships but like
with everything we do we feel like we
have to settle yeah that we won't offend
anyone or we won't [ __ ] up or we don't
think that we're qualified like who says
you can't put out an hour special in the
beginning of your career i want to talk
about your special though
i do because how long have you been
doing comedy for so i've been doing
comedy i'm considered very green i've
been doing it around three years but
i've been i started like seven years ago
working at this company batches where i
was like right i was a seventh hire i
was writing all their tweets their memes
yeah like starting a lot of trends i
also was writing all these like quick
funny videos like snl type sketches for
like millennial girls oh so you've been
in comedy well better yeah and then i
started really honing in on my own
voice like i knew their voice and i
started getting my own voice which is a
little more like
dirty and goofy
and then my i started my podcast yeah
and my friend
someone hit me up and was like do a live
podcast show and my friend was like i
dare you to do 10 minutes of stand up
and i had like dated stand-ups and i had
friends who were stand-ups but
nothing dude i love stand-up comedians i
mean okay not today but they're but they
heard their nightmare i mean i'm married
to one
by the way but i told myself
tell me comedians tell me they're like
you don't want to date a comedian
because they're dark
yes com well the thing is if what kind
of people need to make strangers laugh
every night to feel whole
i'm talking about myself right now but
it's more it's i actually feel like
stand-ups are two types of people
they're like they say they're addicts or
athletes
where like you're they're either like
searching for this high yeah like i was
an athlete where like i just i love the
adrenaline the adrenaline yeah and i
love performing too yeah but just stand
ups are just a certain breed of person
they're not as i don't say simple
because i don't think anyone's simple
right right but we deal with like
anxiety depression yeah
well so does everybody else i mean you
guys just wear it on your sleeve that's
just a different yeah i also think maybe
stand-ups are so dark because like i
love making people laugh more than
anything because i know what it's like
to be so sad right and if you've never
you know how like you're going into it
with the best intention though
yeah
it all started just because i like
making my friends off right yeah and my
family's really funny i just humor is
like the one thing that i always had
yeah where like life
punches you in the face sometimes but
laughter can always be like found in any
scenario yeah it's
[Applause]
[ __ ] right now i just came from therapy
like i'm an open wound what do you guys
want
did you do
so did you realize when you did that ten
minute uh podcast live thing that you're
like oh wait i could actually do stand
up so i for all the girlies out there
who were trying to do stuff by the book
i didn't know that like comedians
actually you start with like two minutes
and you do open mics and you open mics
for like two to three years that's what
they recommend oh god and then you start
getting heat and then you get past at
some clubs and stuff
the first 70 comedy was like caroline's
in front of 300 people i just did 10
minutes because i didn't know what i
didn't i was like dumb confident like i
didn't know
that's kind of the best way to be though
yes and that's what i'm saying like when
you're in your creative [ __ ] yeah don't
look at because also we're not like
trying to be lawyers where it's like you
have to pass this test yeah it's
creativity yeah and also if you think
about it because of my tennis experience
i'm used to dealing with nerve-wracking
situations so i wasn't nervous right but
i do have to say i went into it like no
ego i was like if i love it i'm gonna do
it more yeah and if i hate it it's not
my path yeah did you feel like okay if
i'm gonna bomb this isn't for me so i
remember right before i went on stage
because with tennis i dealt with some
performance anxiety yeah like i felt a
lot of pressure from my parents and from
like
the school i was at coaches and i would
always crack under pressure
like i really i did i was like
i really assumed that you would thrive
under pressure i i do in certain ways
i'm like a weird risk taker
where like some things you're like wow
she's so brave and yeah then other
things you're like why couldn't she do
that yeah like i just deal with a lot of
anxiety and i'm situational yeah and
like i always put myself out there i'll
always put myself up yeah but i'll
either crash and burn yeah or be great
but
but i'll put my i won't quit you know
she's a door yeah so i basically
remember thinking oh my god this could
be like tennis and i'm gonna go on stage
and
i'm gonna blank out right yeah i'm going
to like feel out of my body i'm sweating
i'm going to like
i swear to god i go on stage and i start
talking and i feel like i'm at brunch
with my best friend
and i'm telling you oh it shook me to
the core because i've done a lot of
things that like i'm good at yeah like i
do like cold-calling sales
i've done tennis and i was good at it
because i'm a hard worker yeah but i
always felt sick inside and i just
thought that's what athletes do like
you're good at being uncomfortable yeah
and that's what makes you great but i
didn't realize you could do something
that didn't make you sick all the time
whoa but it was it you kind of found
your calling in a way it was like i ne i
i need to be here like i'm good at this
yeah and in my head they were i was like
that's what my ex did like i don't want
him to think i'm copying him and then i
was like also like this is this male
dominated field yeah it's difficult but
then i was like oh no
you're crazy
and this is where your crazy is in its
most like beautiful form exactly and you
also being comedian is just like
complaining and making people think
differently about things
making people feel less alone you know
what's also fun is like our family i
feel like we have very we're gonna talk
about families because we have an
italian family too and so everyone's
very loud
like that's totally that's why i asked
her because i'm like you could come off
like new yorkers no yeah or like
where's clothes that is like the best
compliment
thanks i don't want to be associated
honestly like people don't when they say
we're from l.a they're like really like
you're born and raised i'm like yeah but
because we're in the thing my point
it's true yeah you are more friendly if
you've been in new york you would have
been a little you would have had a
couple more wrinkles on your face for
sure for sure it doesn't have to be
botox but you've seen some [ __ ]
absolutely
we love the shock factor like that's how
we are like we're one of those people
that if we're staying with all our
girlfriends we'll for sure say the most
raunchy aggressive [ __ ] that has
absolutely no necessary reason to be
there but we just love getting people's
reactions i think that's like i love
getting people's reactions and i was
about to say you guys are really good
interviewers oh what no you are because
you make people feel comfortable and
you're very like you're good listeners
too
and that's like part of
making good interviewers is like getting
reactions out of people yeah i want to
see reactions that's such a confidence
i'm literally getting from like making
like men uncomfortable
[Applause]
like people feel confident i like to get
people to
you feel alive well you know what it is
this is what i would say it's like when
i'm getting to know a girlfriend or i'm
dating a guy whatever it is
y'all are all thinking about the same
things i'm thinking about i'm the only
one that's going to say it first and
then once i kind of like out myself a
little bit yeah then they go oh wait
yeah i do the same thing or whatever it
is well that's the ultimate test of
compatibility if you guys if we enjoy
making a date very uncomfortable yeah
early on just to see how they'll react
and if they can't catch on to our humor
or aren't able to banter off of us we're
like you don't go that's why people are
laughing
at you of you really new york is like
the way i show affection is making fun
of you and if i like you if i'm nice to
you that means i don't like you like if
i'm like super polite and trying to get
out of the conversation
i hate you but if i like look at you and
i start like [ __ ] on something about
your life for sure if you're like oh my
god
it's like it's like school your chicks
my my best friend and i we call it like
gentle bullying we just gentle bullied
yeah oh yeah the whole
life
once every now and then like we'll hug
and we feel so weird but that's my own
intimacy
do i do i like my brothers like
i can't even hug her and she's literally
like what do you do
like it struggled i was like god damn i
was just trying to show like one ounce
in the power show my love for you but
that is a good test in relationships
where like make fun of him and if he
can't spit it back at you he's done yeah
we're bored immediately i'm currently
trying to fall or hide how rich the dude
is if i make fun of him and he can't
spit it back i'm like yawn fest i agree
honestly there's nothing worse than a
boring person my dad always says that
the worst thing you can be is a boring
yeah because that's the worst thing
about that actually i need to tell
myself that because that's like the one
thing i'll never fail at like i feel
like everything else but boring is never
i'm definitely well even here's the
thing
a lot of people don't have it a lot of
you were just naturally a funny person
and you're naturally not a boring person
but sometimes i think we assume that
everyone is the same and they're not and
you're like what is wrong with them
maybe within their family they're not
boring like they have inside jokes yeah
but when you combine different cultures
people are like what's going on i do
think
like growing up in the family that we
grew up in and what i've seen from your
family on tv and social media it's like
they're a huge testament to the way that
we are today being loud and open yeah i
don't know if y'all can relate an
italian family it's like you don't talk
you scream talk scream like you can't
tell if they're fighting or laughing
exactly exactly and it's like any time
we bring our friends over or guys home
whatever it is they don't want to leave
they get stressed because they're like
we can't [ __ ] like keep up get a word
of like
they leave and they come back they're
like wait that was like actually really
fun because they go back to their fans
and no one's saying anything like the
adrenaline yeah
yeah oh my god
we're drug tripped no i don't want more
i don't know
why are you not talking yeah
someone's like a meatball like it's
actually insane what's the most like
italian thing that you think you do that
you got from your family today i mean
food is like love for me and i really
care about
sitting down and eating a meal with
someone yeah that's like my like love
language where like even friends like
you'll hit me up like you wanna do this
you wanna do this but if you're like do
you wanna get lunch with dinner i'm
there yeah and
i have a very classic italian grandma
she's actually on instagram nana's still
got it no she's 80 years old she's
gorgeous [ __ ] fabulous she's fat
you've seen her
yes oh my god wait i'm gonna tell her
that you guys know who she is she's
gonna no i saw her on summer house and
she made this like
sex she's like i'm a sex kitten or like
made a comment like that and she's
wearing a choker and i think i have the
same choker
this guy died she's literally from
brooklyn new york she got married at 18.
she wanted to be an artist told her dad
i want to go to art school yeah and he
cried because he was like you need to
get married so she literally just like
got married to my amazing papa but she
is always glamorous yeah so she always
shows her decolletage she calls it and
she
she always has a meal but she's so
classic italian grandma we're like we're
all eating she's standing yeah
and then she already ate while eating
kind of so she's just like are you gonna
finish that do you want more you don't
want another sausage you don't want
another one and you're like nana i'm
full and she's like you don't like the
sausage oh
and then you're like okay but like and
then next thing you know but she's
looking hot and gorgeous so we're just
like stuffing our faces yeah but like
that's the love is like her force
feeding me right have you ever brought
it okay so obviously your husband's been
met your family but when you bring home
a date or whoever you're seeing
do you if your family doesn't like them
do they tell you immediately or how is
that so if my mom does not like a dude
he's done i've i i've broken up with men
because my mom
i she's one of those people that just
like knows everything and i could try to
be like
she i trust her with my life yeah i will
call her about the littlest things like
what color nails should i get to should
i leave my job or something and
i could try my own thing but she's right
yeah she has the best interest for me
and she's lived life yeah was i look
co-dependent on her for a while i think
i was but i just had to trust my own gut
which is the same as hers yeah but
once i was dating a guy and you know
it's a red flag when you omit stories
from your mom
uh okay you know because like you're
like yeah she's not gonna like that i do
and then but you she likes what you've
told her and one day i was like having
all this anxiety about this relationship
and this guy was like to everyone else
everyone loved him yeah and i like
wanted to be in love with him but like
something was wrong and i finally just
tell her i'm like i don't feel good when
i'm around him i feel like he doesn't
want to hang out with me all the time it
doesn't laugh at my jokes i said like
all this stuff and she was like
you're not going this place tonight and
i was like what and she's like pick up
the phone you're breaking up with him
right now stop did you get it i did it
but to be honest if i didn't do that it
would have been like six more months
panic attacks and stuff because i was
like feeling
off the guy like wasn't good for my
self-esteem but wait what was it about
him that he was off it seemed like for
face value is perfect he's perfect yeah
what was perfect about him i basically i
think you guys probably deal with it a
lot in this industry like he was a um
he was like a performer
and stuff and i really looked up to him
and then
i realized like he was kind of dimming
my light yeah
and
i literally watched a dr dre documentary
where his wife i know very random so
funny but his wife was like
i'm his rock and he's the balloon and i
hold him down i remember watching that
in that moment but i'm not a rock no i'm
nobody's rock like i'm i we should be
switching balanced i agree and then i
remember being like also dr dre and her
did get divorced just fine
see
she's just a rock at the bottom of the
ocean
now hopefully she's making herself a
balloon but i feel like gardeners and
flowers are in relationships and you
should go back and forth totally and i
think he wanted me to kind of be just
like his like support system i hate when
guys are like you check everything off
my list i think that's a red flag
like you're this like thing they're just
trying to fill in where it's like like
that he came up with it
yeah and then i didn't think he was like
deep down rooting for me
and i feel like he had his own [ __ ] that
he wasn't
like he was
he wanted to be really cool yeah and as
a result it was making me not feel good
about myself it's interesting it comes
out in anxiety like you start getting
panic actually where is this coming from
even when it's on the most random day
you're like wait i'm repressing
everything that's going on i feel like
when i'm here i really ship and now it's
just coming out of like me doing my
nails but when i'm here no i [ __ ] tip
my polish
not the polishes but what i do when i
hear guys like this and i've dated guys
like that where i'm like i feel like i
do everything right and i'm fun and i'm
a great time yeah why do why do they
make me feel this way
you're such a personality and you have
so much comedy and like you you make him
feel good and happy all the time but he
in his mind probably can't keep up with
you and he knows that and he's like well
i can't make her laugh as much as she
makes me laugh i can't not as ambitious
i'm not as creative so they have to put
you down like no one throws yeah like i
always say like people throw stones up
they don't throw stones down it's true
and also like even the score keeping
like that should not happen in
relationships it's like we're on a team
together yeah once you feel like they're
like counting how many times like you
helped out or something or that's such a
like marriage look at me and i do that i
edited this week
so you guys are fine
together we always do this but you know
things aren't great when you feel like
people are counting and like testing
and that shit's [ __ ] up how did you
know then dez was different from all the
other ones in germany
oh my god i would love to talk about
that oh do we love his daddy do we love
his daddy
our thing says how does it feel dating
oh my god
we love him no he's literally he's a
silver fox oh and i'm i'm not that girl
who like has always been into older guys
yeah oldest guy i dated was like 36. i
always
i also i think i was a little
emotionally unavailable where i would
like to go for like really hot
like why not it was fun but i almost
like in a feminist way where i was like
yeah i want to be like i'm successful
and i have all these hot guys that i i'm
hanging out with what's your biggest buy
because that's like the reverse what's
the difference it's a guy though like we
had a baller to come and also i wasn't
trying to get married in my early 20s so
i was like i went for guys that i didn't
like respect 100 because if they were to
reject me i'd be like well i wasn't even
into him oh you're protecting your
after emotion available guys i feel like
i kind of would do the same thing before
i go with guys who like i
just had like too much control
and then you'd flip to a guy you have no
control and then you break down because
you're like why can't i control this
person and like not that we're trying to
be controlling [ __ ] but like sorry
that's no it's and we love that word in
england they say we always say see you
next tuesday so it's okay okay see you
next tuesday um
a lot of syllables but you know what i
said
then you swing back to being like okay i
want to feel safe in a relationship and
then you feel too safe that you're bored
and then you go to the other end where
you feel scared and secure and then it's
like
so you're telling us there's a balance
right yes okay guys there needs to be a
tug and pull like because if it gets too
comfortable it is boring i'm sorry like
there's going to be no change and that's
when you start to fight for no reason
and then if it's uncomfortable you just
constantly don't feel enough and then
you're always like i hold stuff in oh
yeah
and then one day i'm like i can't do
this and he's like what
that's
so stressful
i once i got sushi with him and he like
asked about stuff on the menu and i'm
like it's a japanese place they have the
same stuff on every menu everywhere and
then i was like i'm done with him sorry
i'm over it it was three-year
relationship i was like this is that's
the last question
a few for this question like that's not
happening
what is the age difference between you
and dez it's 15 years love that i'm 30.
actually right now he's 46 so i'm 16. i
had seen him do comedy like six years
ago at the comedy cellar and he went up
and he was just like great energy it's
funny i'm from brooklyn he's originally
from queens i feel like you do end up
with someone that feels like home to you
for sure even though we've all traveled
like so he lived in ireland from the age
of 14 on oh my god
because he he basically got sent to
boarding school there and he has family
there so he he has this like interesting
life he also speaks mandarin basically
he's like [ __ ] interesting that's
like where you're talking to someone and
you're gonna constantly learn from
someone like that and like i don't want
to be with someone who's like i'm so
smart i'm gonna teach you everything no
no no i was just like whoa he knows [ __ ]
we're like if i ask him a question i'm
gonna listen yeah yeah like i care i'm
asking because i actually want to know i
just i love helping people too so i'll
be in these relationships where i'm just
constantly like
what do you want to do with your life
i'll help you get there yeah and like do
that with your friends not your partner
yeah yes yes i totally agree like your
partner you don't want to feel like
you're you're always pulling because
eventually i think they resent it if
you're always like you don't like where
you are now yeah no it's like they don't
you don't want to have to try to better
them because you want to be with their
best self exactly right so dez i saw him
do comedy and he was talking about how
he lived in ireland and i was like i
guess i'll never hook up with that guy
and then fast forward i'm in comedy
and
he added me on instagram because we had
mutual friends and he was in ireland
like this is just like the hot irish
comic i swear to god there's i was 29
single living with my parents in long
island yeah with four cats and my mom
even was like so
did you have to work on something within
yourself and i'm like mom i remember
getting annoyed at her and i don't get
annoyed at her very often i was like i
haven't met my person who got away i
said mom who got away out of all the
guys who got away so did she have
anybody that she always used to say who
got away she knows no one got away okay
she hated it i mean yeah
yeah like we were all like everything's
not it's not it yeah there was nothing
that i was like oh i wish that worked
out no yeah so i was like i haven't met
it yeah and i really think like
relationships are like friendships where
you ever meet
someone and immediately you're like i'm
obsessed with this person yeah and they
feel that way too
and i'm telling you yeah
what i wish i knew in my early 20s was a
lot of the time you're like okay i
should have done this i should have said
this and you're like forcing all this
stuff and you're like oh it was me and
or oh he doesn't know i have to get him
to understand me stop
like literally stop right and keep
working on your own [ __ ] and your own
energy because you're just gonna get
brighter and brighter and brighter and
attract a brighter person i think people
forget that's the maturity but i think
people forget that that's just being old
yeah
that's maturing
but i love talking to girlies your age
yeah because it's actually like the most
chaotic scary time and people don't talk
about 26 she's gonna turn 24. yeah 26 24
are powerful like beautiful crazy ages
and i feel like i'm so behind on
everything that's what deciding makes
you think
think about after college which by the
way last year college they're like what
major do you want to do and you're like
i thought it didn't matter yeah and then
yeah it does matter then you're thrown
into life yeah you haven't even tried
the jobs my 20s i had so many different
jobs i dated different guys
and i was you're literally just
researching your 20s are a chaotic
drunken research phase yeah yeah it's
like you're in just like this lazy pool
life is floating and i'm figuring it out
but i told this and i said this on our
last podcast was someone said your 20s
are like you being a newborn into
adulthood yeah so you're basically nine
years old but then you see the social
media and like someone at 25 is in like
forbes thirty under third and yeah and
they're like cured cancer and you're
like oh my god so i know failure i don't
even know what to do but that's
it's not normal that is like the zero
percent and also like some people who
have gotten really successful at a young
age it's like that's almost their peak
or like they fight the rest of their
life to like like remember when
yeah like even people getting famous
really young then they like missed that
high right like when they were like 15
on a disney show yeah and then you're
like yeah and then some of these kids
are starting at like 15 what they end up
getting successful at 25. like yeah but
then they didn't life is a marathon not
a sprint yeah and for uh the girls in
their early 20s
my only thing that i'm pressuring you to
do
is to literally try everything to
understand what brings you joy right
because your only job is when you're in
your 30s and
there's a reason why at 25 years old
people quit their job and go on yoga
retreats like that's like a thing yeah i
know it's true because you should go
find yourself you do i i recently did
like a speak a speaking gig about career
moves and i always say think of the job
that society your parents you think you
should do
and then think of the job that's like
crazy that you'd be like embarrassed to
tell people what you want to do yeah
yeah
that's a job you need to start going for
so actually in your 20s because then
what are we doing special effects makeup
oh my god that's amazing i've always
been what are you talking about i've
always i've always
that's what i love effects makeup you
have no idea hannah this is what i don't
tell people okay you're shaming her
you're saying
you're different you're shaming
but also if we think about it you don't
even i also think like certain goals are
restricting we're like in five years we
don't even know what the technology will
be for that kind of makeup so like
you figuring out today like
you love the pod you like modeling what
are little steps you can take to
research the industry to hang out with
people who do that as well to start your
own channel where maybe you're [ __ ]
around with intense stuff like right
it's the difference between
people who are really successful not
successful is literally just the time it
takes them to like decide to take action
yeah because people will freeze for
years they're just frozen i feel like
i'm crazy you might do it tomorrow and
be like wait i'm sorry i actually hate
it it takes forever but at least you
know you know why that's what your 20s
is for not when you're 35 have a family
hate your job wish you tried special
effects if your mom had told you don't
do this do you think it would be harder
for you to jump into like crazier
careers oh my god great question because
i feel like i so i mean i i would say
like our our mom she's super supportive
of us but then of course she's gonna say
like i don't use a realistic goal it's
not realistic
and that's not because she's doing it to
hold us back she's just trying to make
sure that we don't fail at something or
whatever it is yeah so and that's fine
that's just what a mom does sometimes
yeah she wants to protect you exactly
but for me sometimes i take it like oh i
can't i shouldn't do it like at all she
said no so i don't do it yeah and that's
just like my own anxiety and i'm frozen
well she's also projecting her anxiety
onto you and you probably get that
anxiety from yes
because and it's not that you start
realizing that your parents are seeing
you through a lens of their own
experiences yeah and my mom for example
like she was a first-person woman to go
to college in her family and then she
wanted to be a jazz singer but she
didn't because like her brother was
trying to do more creative stuff and she
said she like she ended up being a
teacher and she like went her whole life
doing that so she kind of regretted that
she didn't try something crazy so to me
she's like [ __ ] go off go i love it and
now she's retired and she's singing jazz
you're not supposed to be the best at
anything yeah like yeah they're a little
when i see someone do something great in
their 20s it's like cool it's a [ __ ]
marathon yeah and
this is a stupid quote but i like
metaphors we're all like popcorn okay
where like the temperature will be the
same yeah but people are gonna pop at
different times and that's just science
yeah i love that i like that i actually
like that
[Laughter]
but but also you guys are already like
putting yourself out there nobody's
doing this podcast it's being a creator
i think that you're constantly thinking
you're seeing everyone else doing
creative stuff and they're like changing
avenues all and maybe they've been in it
for a little bit longer like what can i
do more how can i be more successful
yeah and maybe that's just like our ego
or insecurity wanting to just like but
it also like makes them successful and
it's a thing
the goal for me is like i want to wake
up
and be happy at the end of the day
and you
you have to put yourself in the best
situation with the best people around
you
to literally just be happy because i
don't care how much money you're making
it's not gonna suffice yeah if you're 32
and feeling empty yeah cause you hate
your job yeah because in your 20s you
were doing what everyone what you
thought everyone wanted you to do anyway
else and that's when it comes to
relationships too you were like with you
and dads you're like i found this guy we
hit it off immediately and you didn't
realize you could find that immediate
spark you're such a good mentor and
influence for women in their 20s no
seriously because i think it's because
i've i've had to do a lot of work on
myself yeah and i like i love talking to
you guys because i wish i had someone
saying that to me in my early 20s
because i'm [ __ ] type a and very hard
on myself
but um yeah and i feel like yeah i i
attract like other girls who are like
that and i just want women to take over
the world i do the gays domination
[Laughter]
but i really what i really like um about
your relationship is i think sophie and
i put a lot of pressure on ourselves to
like find our person by the time we're
27. be engaged by this number our body
clock is running out have babies buy
this number and popcorn popcorn
literally gonna send your dm and be like
popcorn popcorn just like an emoji
and you get like literally put a popcorn
like sticker on the back of your phone
so but you waited and you found the
perfect person at the perfect time for
you
i hope that it gives i hate when people
were like it'll work for me and you're
like okay well that's you yeah but also
it makes people feel better i quit i was
doing like marketing
i hated my job i was like
i saw an old video i used to do some
like on-screen stuff for wisconsin
athletics when i played tennis like
broadcasting yeah like in my last
semester because i knew sports and i
loved it and i want to be on camera but
then i didn't want to move to like a
small city and i just went back to new
york i had some ideas of doing like a
fun youtube channel and then i got into
sales but i needed that time to show my
parents like see i can make money doing
corporate [ __ ] i don't want to do it
i'm not happy and and it didn't make me
happy i hated myself and then at 25 i
literally quit my job
and said
all i manifested was i want to do video
that's all i put into the universe i
want to do video i didn't know if it was
going to be sports so i took a unpaid
internship doing a sports video editing
thing which i wasn't even editing i was
like sending them data and i always say
tell people your dreams like i that was
really powerful when you finally said
out loud because you know when you keep
something as a secret it almost feels
naughty and dirty
and bad yeah and i know you put it out
and she was like oh but like you said it
i said it's my youtube history that's
all i watch you said it and it's real
yeah and then
you don't know like who might listen to
this pod and be like actually and dm you
about something like that you're putting
it out there and some people are like
don't don't jinx it [ __ ] that
because i always talk about everything i
want to be doing with my life and then
i'm like if you were like but if you say
it too much like it's gonna not happen
i'm like you know what if i don't say it
enough then i'm never gonna believe that
it could happen totally if you keep it
as like a dirty little secret that means
you don't actually believe in it yeah
that is so true that's so and also i
didn't really believe but i just like i
wanna do video then someone overheard me
say i wanna do video and said oh batches
is looking for a video person with five
years experience mind you i just had
like six months of little editing so we
lie
we did not lie oh wait i can't i i
submitted a funny video that was like
how they were getting up i submitted
and like
it was so fun and easy for me i'm like
it's like making my friends laugh yeah
yeah i sent it they called me and they
go you have no experience
but that video was funny and i and i
went in and i had like 20 other video
ideas for them and i just was like
i can try this i can do this so that was
my yeah i will like go to a job and
instead of being like this is why i
should hire me i go this is what i'm
literally going to do for you yeah these
are my ideas right so smart but this is
what i'm passionate about it's really
what you're passionate about you're
going to be great and they paid me 300 a
week and i was i was 26 at that point
okay yeah no i was 25 or turning 26. and
like definitely there were people who
were like hannah's not doing so well oh
yeah no job 25 working like whatever
in two years i was on a tv show it's so
true and you know what i how did you
ever think that that would happen like
did you ever think you'd be on a reality
show though
no i never thought that's like a totally
different ball game but again i'm one of
those people that's like [ __ ] it let's
do it why not and like i had great
experiences on it right i also had bad
experiences on it but like it was all
research for me yeah and for me i i see
myself as an entertainer so i just had
to keep putting myself in different
places until i found like the right
space for me and it might change i'm
also very open to like everything's
moving our brains are changing
i could wake up tomorrow and be like i
don't like stand up and start like
acting like i don't [ __ ] know you
would be a good actor
but actually that's how i got into your
podcast because i am a giggler i will
say
i was kind of wondering how you guys
know me because you're kind of like a
little cool or not
like you're cool but not that i mean i
have close fans but you guys are like
cool we are but we're really no but
hannah's like
no you're goofy you're really goofy like
that's the thing it's like listening to
this so i watch you on summer house and
i watch you and paige and your
friendship was hysterical and i'm like
i need more of this injected into my
veins you have your podcast giggly squad
and i'm not kidding you guys you have to
check it out i've never missed an
episode i think it's
to god the hysterical you guys have is
so good and like that's how i'm i'm
trying to secretly like act like i don't
know a lot about you but like i know
everything
about you're gonna make me i'm gonna
talk about you guys next episode
the giggly squad originated again like
from
[ __ ] happened where like i am now not on
the reality show with my best friend
yeah and the best part of the reality
show was us together but they kind of
stopped showing our like actual funny
friendship yeah because what's more like
people they almost were like oh people
love hannah and paige let's see the
drama and like that wasn't that's not
where i succeed yeah i will like cry and
just [ __ ] it up so right we started
doing all these instagram lives together
and then i was like okay no one can take
it from us if we just do it together
and it's the my favorite time of the
week me just
busting my friends balls laughing at our
own jokes too much yeah right and the
amount of girls that have related to us
and i think it's also because we're not
trying to be
we want it to be so wrong unedited
because people see us through such like
a screen that's right so like dissected
into like a weird narrative through
other people
like imagine your life being narrated by
people who don't like you like that's
just scary
so
we've just been ourselves and i feel
like there's
it's important to have like a female
friendship that's
like
nuanced yeah that's not so simple yeah
and that's what i got from listening to
your podcast that you saying it's
unedited and it's raw
it's truly like that's how you know you
guys are so authentic because you're
just sitting on a couch with no
production like no lights no no camera
like you're in your sweatpants two
microphones and it just
works and it's so relatable
and you guys went on tour right like you
did a few livestreams so we're going to
do more live shows
we're going to be in new york though
we'll come back don't you worry about me
we'll put a new one yeah yeah
i have to oh my god it's totally free
but i'm coming for you it's in september
perfect i'm coming yesterday
i'm gonna say oh baby
i miss you i just have to do something
real quick i'll see you one night
but also a page is a great example like
paige has taught me a lot about myself
where she's someone who it's really easy
with like yeah we've had our ups and
downs but like in terms of chemistry
that's just a type of person and i
really think friendships and
relationships you have to treat them
kind of similar where it's like you
don't force it yeah if you start feeling
shitty around them yeah you either like
try to fix it or you're out yeah and
back to dez
during it was during quarantine that he
moved from ireland back to long island
where his family has a house for you or
just in general he didn't he didn't know
you know i was there and we were like
quarantining for months out there not
knowing we were there and he just
i was like facetiming some football dude
i was having like you know summer house
guys calling me all the time but you
know when you were just like we are
spinning and it's going nowhere
and dez just goes hey are you out east
and i was like yes and just like that
and then he goes do you want to get
coffee inside harbor and i said yes
here's my digits
and and then i sat down and people have
stories like oh i talked to them for 10
hours and that does happen a lot but
sometimes it's a dopamine hit sometimes
you're just like i agree high on it and
then you lose it and then you go like
those are the hardest ones to get over
yeah i technically hate them like the
first four days and then i'm like wait
actually like you wait did you
immediately like them in the video did
you immediately feel it when you met him
so i because i've never been with an
older dude part of me was like will i
even be into it like that right i knew i
was gonna be interested in him because
he's like a really successful comic yeah
so of course i was gonna have fun yeah
yeah bantam is gonna be off the charts
literally i got there and i was like
complaining about my dad cause he
dropped me off early in the 90 degree
heat because he had a tea time and i'm
like dad this is the first date i've had
in months no sweating literally my groin
is sweating because of you and you're
always like oh do you want to meet
someone i'm like this is your one time
to support me because i was like in a
bad mood
and i sit down like a [ __ ] dad
and he's like at least your parents are
alive
because both his parents passed away and
i'm not laughing no we start crying oh
yeah that's just like anything this is
when you picked me up and in that moment
i was like i'm i'm obsessed with you
dark creepy man
i think that was the test for you
because you could have been like oh my
god i'm so sorry again i could have got
in the car someone could be like this
[ __ ] is annoying and it's nothing
against you it's their lens they're
viewing you through yeah or he could
have said the joke and i could have been
like that's so dark dark and weird and i
and that's probably happened to him and
it's definitely happened to me probably
oh easily but it's the same level of
like i do think humor is what connects
like he says he's like my love language
is laughing and i'm like okay well can
you get more gifts like what is that
about but when in doubt we find humor in
each other yeah um and that's important
to me and he does feel like home like
the good and the bad like things i'm
like that my dad's literally said that
to me before or but it like it's my yeah
it's my comfort right right and he calls
me out on my [ __ ] do you think that did
you because sincerely says this you
don't really know someone until you have
your first fight did you feel like that
with him too because like you probably
had like this high of like always
getting along but did you ever have like
a moment where you guys it depends like
how you guys fight because if you can
resolve it and understand each other
just fine
that's a really good point yeah i have a
whole stand-up bit about like the first
date should be a fight and like take it
to the cmv
like take them to home goods and like
sniff all the candles and see if he gets
upset
like say you want to switch meals with
him
like on the food box
because it's like you i say like when
you're you're you're both hot and you're
both acting on your best behavior you
can get along with anyone for six months
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like you know the time
like you know when you they suddenly
start showing sides to them and i'm like
why didn't you show me that in the
beginning yeah like
six months in
and then you're like well i already put
six months in i guess and he's tall so i
guess i'll stay he's tall i say i always
say the amount of months he is above six
feet is the amount of months i stay with
him after discovering he's a monster
i'll be like okay you're six four four
i'm like onto the [ __ ] the more
interesting you are the loss of a
personality you need to have it's fine
oh yeah it's not true
it's just close your eyes to the sun
yeah
you don't really need to he's like i
frosted tips i don't really need to have
them but i was guilty of like dudes
would be so boring and i'd be like no
he's great you try to make them better
in your head yeah because i like the
idea i love the idea of stuff
the thing with me and dez is so we go on
four dates and we're like into each
other and he's like
freaked out he be it's i basically have
to go to summer house and it's not
filming a normal season we're it's
coveted so we lost in the house yes i
thought weeks
oh i had i was fully having mental
breakdowns every day at one point i was
like i'm like am i supposed to have this
much diarrhea like this isn't even
normal
like i literally have so much weight and
i was anyway pure anxiety
and he was like look obviously like
you're gonna be with like a guy you're
also talking to like do what you have to
do i'm here after and i was like
mature yeah
wow then i get there and it's like [ __ ]
immediately is hitting the fan and i
started calling him every night
and i would like the joke was i would
like call him i'd be crying and then he
would like calm me down and then like
pump me up and then i'd get angry and
then we'd like have phone sex and then
we just talk about like get to know each
other so we have like full like five
hour podcasts every night together oh
wow but think of i was i'm such a like
i'm a chill girl like i'll be like in
your apartment freezing because the ac
is too cold and i won't say a thing i'll
be like yeah perfect in here
where it does i call it i'm like
this guy's so mean to me
you feel like you could be so you're so
comfortable immediately you're like i
can cry i guess like and he's like we
low-key like we're i'm italian like i'm
passionate yeah i'm either like i'm a
passionate person i'm not boring so i
was just giving him but it was it was
way heightened drama for like what it's
actually like to
mean like date me
while i'm filming a reality show every
like every day i had like four story
lines everyone had a comment they're
like his age where is he like oh well so
he wasn't even supposed to come really
but
he like he didn't even tell his agent
like it wasn't like a thing he should do
for his career necessarily it's kind of
risky and he comes and he was like so
nice to everyone at one point he like
ordered pizza and we all ate it in my
room and then they were like stay
stay with him and let people go on the
boat and i'm like sure so we stayed we
were like having all this fun yeah and
then they were like okay he has to leave
he has to leave he leaves and like a guy
comes up to me and was like we don't
know if we like him and then someone was
like yeah he didn't hang out with the
group enough he was there for two days
and i i've been talking on the phone
with this man for five weeks and he was
so nice to everyone so i'm stabbing i'm
like oh my god
cause there's nothing worse literally
all my friends look to me and they're
like you should have hung out with us
more and i know it's like a story line
they're doing but i know that they're
going to edit it like he's not like he's
now with people especially when he's
literally doing a flavor for the show
well you feel bad for him because you're
like he didn't sign up for well exactly
so i'm immediately panicking being like
oh no no no no
and
then he but so our good our first like
fight
was
when
basically like i think started air and
i'm just like getting upset yeah and his
whole thing was like
stop watching the episodes stop reading
the comments but it's like when things
are going bad you want to see how bad
yeah and so we would kind of fight on
because he's
wiser than me in the entertainment world
where he's he's never dealt with this
level of social media right but he knows
what it's like to be in the public eye
and he was like i he's like i made the
most money ever my career when the most
people hated me because just the most
people knew who i was and i talked that
much [ __ ] so he kind of was like you're
in right now
but i would like it would pop up on my
tick tock someone being like why i'm i
think hannah berner isn't you know yeah
and i'd be like
no and he would like stop looking at
your phone and i'd be like okay well i
just need you i need to
to be here for me i'm like yeah but this
is day 400 of this and i'm like but it's
it's really hard yeah really tv is a
certain kind of toxic no it is
the whole reality is literally trying to
get a reaction out of people do you hate
this person yeah we're going to make you
hate this person they choose
so is that why you left you were like
this is i'm already too toxic well my
thing is he also then he proposed and
you're like wait
survive anything so the fact that you
guys stuck through then that is amazing
it's true i do have to say
it
if we were gonna bro break up that was
when
like we never came close to it but i
remember just waking up and like
that's why i say relationships aren't
perfect like relations aren't perfect
because your life isn't perfect yeah and
this man stayed with me through the
probably the most traumatic
career thing that's ever happened to me
and and my and he still wasn't my
personality is like you're gonna like me
because i'm successful and then the guy
that i want to fall in love with is
literally looking at his phone being
like people hate me
i'm just like it's embarrassing
and it's embarrassing you're ashamed and
then you start getting secure around him
you're like does
does he think i'm worse and i also go
from a high of everyone thought i was
like
truth the funny truth teller and i was
like kind of cocky going into it like i
could i could put myself out there i
could stand up for myself
and he's i want this guy to fall in love
with me and like he's getting dms about
like how could you be with him
oh so i was i was a wreck
but i and i was like rightfully so but
it i guess you still have to be like
that was a part of me and he stayed with
me through that yeah and it got to a
point where
it all happened also right after he
proposed wait oh wait seriously so how
long were y'all dating before you
prepared great question so we went on
like a couple dates i did summer house
but we were like talking every night
like
they try to make it like oh i had a
boyfriend she didn't tell people no i
got to know this guy over the month yeah
and then was like come visit and then
when he visited i was like i'm like i
was even nervous like what if i don't
like how he smells like i forgot what he
kind of looks like yeah
and then he came in and i was like oh i
forgot your tall and i'm going to climb
like a tree yeah and it was nice but
right after summer house we get
i got back to like my parents and he
lives in west hampton and after like two
weeks he was like
so like just stay with me
and i'm in this house yeah
just like moving part of me it wasn't
like the movies where the guy's like
here's my key yeah like slide it
very casually was like you should just
like stay here for me
what does that mean well that that's why
i couldn't tell if he was like okay well
you should i guess stay with me because
we don't want to go back and forth or
was he like wanting it and i was like
this is a big decision because you
actually wanna bring it overnight yeah
yeah holy [ __ ] so you just like moved in
so i basically i was like dude i can't
tell if you want me to or you're like
trying to be nice yeah yeah and he was
like no i want you to and i was like
i got this place i said get the dump the
dumpster we're throwing your crap out no
he had like a lot of crap oh so you went
in there i wouldn't do everything i i've
never done this the kind of like
like you want like pillows like i wish
nesting they call it i've never nested
before
place and i might get the dump truck we
threw it all out and then we had the
most beautiful
like
four months
of
just like alone in west hampton we were
like fostering dogs it was like magical
okay yeah and then he so summer house
filmed the whole um fall
he proposed on valentine's day in
february oh
and then
the show starts airing the next month oh
[ __ ] and [ __ ] in the [ __ ] okay
horrible
the next six months were like the worst
six months like damage control for what
happened months ago well
well yeah cause then it and also it airs
when and i'm gonna tell you when it
filmed like it was hard
but like everyone got along at the end
yeah i actually like how to like i was
okay the way it aired and what what
things were shown was like worse it was
way way worse in my situation where like
you have to defend yourself against
things that aren't like true
against the person you love and you
don't know
how to if the more you speak or then
people like just don't say yeah i think
it'll pass exactly because like it's not
true and then you start trying to speak
up for yourself and then you get
yourself so i'm sorry it was just drama
drama drama drama and we also because we
got engaged i think that also made it
like summer house wasn't making sense
where like when i was single it was fun
to be on the show but now you also dez
is sober no one talks about it he came
in the house he's sober and they were
like he didn't play beer pong with us
and i'm like he can't [ __ ] give the
guy
he was hanging out in the kitchen like
it wasn't i think he could have done
anything he could have made a buffet of
food and they'd be like you forgot
potatoes like they would have found out
that's where you guys like reality tv
with stuff or just situations in life
you think back you're like what could i
have done differently and there's
obviously things you could have done
differently but sometimes like the
outcome was going to be the same yeah
yeah cause i avoided even like worse
things they were trying to do
and it's still it's still it's too much
well it just shows you even after an
engagement everything and all the summer
house [ __ ] y'all still made it out and
almost stronger and had the best themed
wedding ever which i still don't
understand
miami and that's my dream bachelorette
i was talking [ __ ] about it like joking
like i'm gonna have a garage wedding i'm
gonna have like people i feel like
envisioned the most ratchet [ __ ] that i
was gonna do and then i feel like i
under promise over delivered
wait yeah cause
people are like wait this is nice
i'm gonna give them the worst
description of a wedding yeah you really
are like their expectations
as she described it was literally like a
small like garage wedding and then she
was like no i'm having a disco tulum
dolphins like
beach wedding anyone sacrificed human
sacrifice you know what happened i
discovered wedding tick tock which like
you're not gonna care about until you
like start thinking about this stuff but
you start putting in like wedding
aesthetic and you see these like shots
of people in certain aesthetics and
you're like oh they're like what is me
what is it what is it putting your sign
and then you're like dolphins so i was
pulling stuff
and literally i decided i needed like on
the beach brooklyn tulum dolphin wedding
and
we kind of nailed it yeah no you did it
it was a doctor wedding
amanda savory was my wedding planner and
she's like [ __ ] incredible yeah she
killed it but i i trusted them like i i
gave them my yeah
i didn't even see the tablescape before
i didn't went to the wedding i just
trusted them wow that's a lot of trust
cause girl you gotta you there's certain
things you could stress about and on my
wedding day i was like i wanna be trying
yeah that's true that's pretty much all
i want to worry about and and they're
going to do better than me yeah like i
told them what i want and i'm paying
them because they're good at like what
they do that's what they do but i do
have to say i can tell you the rules to
the best miami bachelorette of my life
please tell me because what are the
rules of my dream i'm going to give you
guys because i'm going to plan
and we would say our little sister
scarlett's also going to be a man of
water but she's like
scarlet's going to give like the oddball
recommendations no she's gonna we're
gonna end up like with no shoes on it i
think my bachelorette party is gonna be
with her and my younger sister the most
insane thing in the world tell us the
checklist okay the checklist is it's
about energies you gotta get the right
girls around you
you can't just invite people because
like political and stuff you have to be
like who is going to bring the party
who's going to be fun but did that cause
drama because i feel like trying to
select who would go is like
who do you want to keep a drama with one
family member because they like
apparently wanted to come but i was like
we're not close she wasn't like in a
she's pregnant okay forget it you're out
you're out no
i think she wanted the invite but like
in my head i was like we don't want to
kill no time
for this i'm like paige was joking she's
like they won't even let her in the club
no don't even let her club and you have
to feed them babies
that's that's an extra that's that's the
plus two people like it would have been
totally nice of me to invite her but
like i wasn't [ __ ] around with that
[ __ ] i was like we're blacking out yeah
and i also i would have been worried
about her the whole thing and she would
have been like yeah you know you guys
all right bad people pleaser yeah yeah
is the baby okay
it's the strip around 11
hitting the stomach on the
literally you can't you can't break that
bitch's water sls falling in the
clubhouse no no
her water breaks
she gets rejected at the club and i'm
like bye bye
figure your way home everyone's supposed
to imagine yeah so anyway
i had i basically said i don't want to
do bridesmaids but then i because i was
like i think it's like very this is an
old reference but like myspace top eight
with myspace
would pick people and then you like drop
people out and i was like i literally
hate that i didn't want any drama like
that but then i started putting my
friends together and i was like wait
these are nine
perfect women yeah it just happens to
work perfectly yeah and they didn't all
know each other but i and they were all
main character energies but i knew oh
yeah i i just it wasn't the kind of bad
shot where everyone was like let's give
a speech about how great hannah was it
was like what is paige wearing what is
this person joking about we all just
made each other laugh so hard i love but
that's what a bachelorette party is yeah
you can have like the whole formal thing
but do that for like your engagement
about the energy you invite and you
bring that and the energy also my rule
is bachelorettes that are like feel like
you're at camp where it's like okay 10
a.m we're doing yoga so no no no no i
had no plans during the day just each
night we had a dinner and an outing but
during the day i text people and be like
if you're sleeping a good but i'm at the
pool and then we have like we drink all
day at the pool the girls who want the
girls who don't they don't sleep yeah
and
then around like six
paige was so she got me a gift to get my
makeup done every night because she
didn't want to look better than me every
night
like she wanted me to like at least like
put an effort so everything at six
o'clock i'd be like bye [ __ ] and that
was the only one wait i got my makeup
done perfect so we
themes are can be very corny and i don't
i also hate dressing up in themes
because i'll like get drunk and be like
i don't feel like myself i don't feel
cute anymore yeah you give a like
aesthetic
that you let everyone do their own thing
with so i was like first night feathers
and you see what people do with it you
know what feathers were in yeah like
when you got married there'll be things
that are in so like everyone had a
different kind of feather i love that
that's really cool and then we did like
like space cowgirl which like you could
do whatever you want people that's crazy
whatever they oh i love it i felt like
hogwarts going i hate when everyone's
like everyone's wearing this bathing
suit no no and then it's like different
body types are you kidding me someone's
like it's hanging out you can't do that
all one piece and she's like nobody even
brings me dresses you can't just give
them one dress i can't like yeah yeah
yeah
it's like not everyone's the same some
people have these i love these i'm a
people pleaser so i wanted everyone to
have fun but i got to calm at least i
basically get joy out of seeing other
people have fun because of me yeah like
when people at one point i swear to god
everyone was talking to a new person no
one was talking to me everyone's bored
with me and you're like i've done it but
i literally was watching and i started
to get jealous i was like hey not too
close remember i put you two together
yeah you're my friend it made me so hap
like i did not need to talk to anyone i
was sitting there just like um so it was
like a drama dream this is a fun sense
oh i wanted drama i was like one girl
walked in with like an eggshell bathing
suit i said [ __ ] that's white i have
one rule
we were just laughing but the next key
that you have to do
you have to invest
in a photograph for the weekend so
really think what so smart what everyone
wants to look cute for the photo right
yeah think of the time that it takes for
the girls to take each other's photos be
like can you take more i don't like this
can you take mine stress stress we had
basically a paparazzi with us at all
times the first dinner
everyone gets ready we're all sitting at
dinner waiting for appetizers i go
sierra it's your turn she gets up goes
outside does a full photo shoot comes
back i go okay it's my turn this is so
jeans i don't even think it's so sweet
we spend more time together not taking
photos you have a professional
photographer you want to look instagram
the same aesthetic for the photos and
you're like oh that was from hannah's
bachelorette
like everyone knows it was from because
these girls are still posting those
photos yeah like it was amazing and he
gave us like a whole gallery where you
go to the group photos
and then i'd be like okay you two take a
photo with me and and he was also very
chill yeah a freak armando he's amazing
yeah and he he like ate with us he
partied with us oh sick and he was just
like really fun perfect so first night
well we stayed at the good time hotel oh
that's great
is it fun yes
small rooms okay but
i like with three girls in one bed and
one and i was like let's do it but some
girls were like i want my own room yeah
yeah like paige and sierra got a huge
room
somehow and like i did not but like
that's just that's how that's our friend
how it crumbles i was like actually i'd
rather them like be happy and i like
literally sleeping between becca and
haley
but it did feel like a fun like it's
like a sleeping party like it's like a
long walk because when are you gonna do
that when you have a husband no what was
your favorite club going to
okay the best club
by far
was
so first we went to swan the first night
just to eat which is a nice vibe it's a
really nice vibe you feel like you're in
like um
a
jungle a magic jungle and then and
coming from new york we were like yeah
it's like like a nice coral tree cafe
yes yeah
then we go to 11.
here we go where
[ __ ] went down paige got like the best
table for us where we told the security
guards we go no
no men no no men are allowed no they
were clotheslining people like like we
were just like that is like a guy hey
and you'd be like and we'd be like [ __ ]
you guys we were like all the girls are
welcome i love you this girl next to me
was just like pouring vodka down my
mouth and i had a full
it's the first time out i've puked since
like i'm 24
literally was like
and then i go to the bathroom knees on
the tile knees on the toes
that's the false
i wish more came out but it was like
afterwards you were like
i'm back
kiss paige
then people started to leave it was like
2 30 but i was like
i was just so high on like it's really
the perspective like i'm that person
who's out parting and i overthink it i'm
like this isn't fun i shouldn't be here
i'm gonna be tired tomorrow i will look
in the mirror and be like why is
everyone else having fun not me i'm an
anxious partier yeah
but because it was like a celebratory
moment of all these people out here
for like to be with you
was like i was so into it yeah a normal
song would come on that'd be like this
and i'd be like
like it was just like there was everyone
was on a high because everyone loves you
wants to celebrate you so it's just like
so dude i went through [ __ ] some
friend drama on tv so to have like my
real people
who are like publicly being like we love
her yeah kind of meant the world to me
because i had getting excluded from a
friend group is like so painful and then
imagine it happening
on a tv show and i'm like wait so i'm 29
and like you can really forget yeah you
can like rewind really well
you know certain groups like of course
you're the lazer group you don't fit in
with them right they're not right right
right right and
but you still feel like a [ __ ] loser
so to have my friends like with me and
be like celebrate my life with me yeah
it was amazing but then this is what
happened
[ __ ] ja rule comes out
[Laughter]
when i was 11 i'm 30 when i was 11. he
was like the first time i watched mtv he
was like shirtless with ashanti like
yeah yeah and i was like i'm naughty
so he goes on stage
and he's loving it he's rapping and
we're like from me to the camera to him
and we are screaming yeah lyrics back at
him yeah
me and sierra just like go go go i must
have loved you guys
at one point i'm like are him and sierra
dating
we were like having so much fun some of
the girls literally missed it
yeah so then the next morning we wake up
and then you spend all day just you're
dead yeah you're dead but you've got the
pool dead you're in quesadilla's dead
and then you rally the next day
i did i got a boat the boats are fun in
miami you gotta do them
all right we got hooked up like some
friend had like a mega yacht and oh so
it like kind of just we joked i was like
guys it's like
it's kind of clinky it's kind of a
little dingy
like we really and then they were like
freaked out like below deck situation
but like this is a problem i think i
would have actually had more fun on a
smaller boat because it was so big that
you're like where is everyone that's
like the best problem it's almost yeah
you're like we all were sitting on the
top and we were like and all the other
you know smaller boats are being like
crazy and then we were just like can we
have summer champagne i just have a
question so did dez have a bachelor
party oh my god okay this is i have a
question do you have rules for him
because i know a lot of my friends that
are like getting married they're like no
strippers know this or they're like i
don't give a [ __ ] just don't talk about
it so dez is unique because he's a wise
older man we love he i go do you wanna
have a bachelor party and he's like my
whole life
was a bachelor party at this point he
goes i'm just gonna close my eyes and
remember things and i was like ew that's
what he's done he's like my back's
already sleeping now he's gotta do it
come on so he like
he basically didn't have one oh and then
he sees ours is like so lit yeah and
then basically like the week before the
wedding he had all his irish friends
came but like i was in the house with
them and they just cut they got to be
boys like they they like i don't know
what boys do but i was like kind of a
part of it i didn't want to like we
played tennis oh so you went to his
backyard i kind of was it was like a
bachelor week for him and probably the
night before his brother was like bro we
have to go street club we haven't gone
to strip club and does like honestly i'm
tired i don't really want to go
would you have cared if he had gone
no not at all but i do have to say you
giving your man like restrictions like
okay maybe temporarily you feel good but
like you're not
guys are who they are
there's just certain kind of guys that
like obviously they like a strip club
but they don't love it i think it's a
red flag when a guy is
into a strip club more than 20 times 100
yeah i think it's a little bit weird i
think it's like a it has been a few
times for like i can't feel like dudes
love strip clubs yeah they're not
they're not my kind of guys yeah and
they're not attracted to me either right
like right not we don't have the
facilities we're not built that way yeah
there's like guys i've i've dated
they've never been once like follow a
lot of instagram models oh that's yeah
it's and it's not like oh they're not
dicks it's just that's a certain kind of
dude yeah
and i've never and those kind of guys i
think are more into materialistic [ __ ]
so they're never that into me because
i'm like kind of gross
and you gotta just go forward with the
grossness i'm attracting the right
energies for me so i think for your
friends like what are you gonna say
don't go to like then he just it'll make
him want to go more and then he's
bitching his friends like she won't let
me go guys
you literally go on like look at your
phone he's asking and be like yeah do
whatever you want like literally don't
give a [ __ ] and then they care they're
like [ __ ] wait she doesn't care she
doesn't want to do the right thing more
just to make you happy or they also
really think and turn like what do i
actually want to do not to like be
rebellious or yeah cause it's like when
you like hold something too tight it
wants to run yeah it's like restricting
a cable we're going to do this it's true
exactly
don't hold something so [ __ ] tight
just hold it this one night i mean if
you're already thinking that your
husband or whatever is going to cheat on
even the bachelorette you shouldn't
primarily also like if you're just going
to cheat on you it's not going to be a
strip club it's not going to be strip
club like if it was like him paying a
girl to dance on him yeah that's just
like if you're already going in without
any trust for him then there should be
such an a real there needs to be a
reevaluation what's what's going on here
exactly you know like real
trust issue going on because like if
you're jealous of like a girl who
probably hates him and you're just
trying to get paid that yeah and you're
like she's supposed to go home she's
like honestly you're so annoying
tell me one stripper that's genuinely
really she's like happy to be there she
has to deal with all these guys every
single week and going there for the same
reason you think she's gonna go focus on
your guys
also let's be honest he's gonna be so
[ __ ] drunk i literally just tweeted
like for a girls bachelorette party fun
it has to have like loyalty organization
like your firstborn it has to be like so
[ __ ] all out where like steve sees
half a nipple and he's like that's a
great weekend yeah it's like let him
have this happening
tell me one time as a girl oh you want
to shoot a guy i know i have a question
so your man is sloppy he's drunk of
course he's at his bachelor party tell
me one time as a girl you've looked at
me like that's hot
he's gonna be blackout he's back out
he's that's mine
back sweat and his pit stains yeah and
him not even getting he's rolling back
his pores smell like
she's not i don't know i have like that
connection yeah suddenly like that's the
man of her dreams i am a missionary
though for older men so for girls
listening also i think dating's hard in
your 20s because the guys are also
figuring [ __ ] out yeah they figure out
what they want they also don't know how
their dick works and like there's just a
lot like god like these poor women what
we have to go through in our early 20s
when like because you don't know you're
like oh is that how it's supposed to
feel
okay
okay okay and then you're with an older
man you're like hey
yeah
i also i there is something we said too
about emotional maturity i don't think
girls are necessarily like smarter than
men all the time but also faster
faster so like you're talking to
squirrel and you're wondering why the
squirrel and you are not hitting it off
you're talking to squirrel you know
that's what i'm calling guys in their
20s um they have little nut brains
they're not brains
he can't even help what's happening
so i do think
date older guys raise your age range my
age range was like 34 what the [ __ ] am i
thinking cause you're thinking like that
traditional family when it's like date
also like don't marry these guys just
learn from them yeah and also i like how
they're confident in their careers
because then they're less intimidated by
you yeah totally which is why i [ __ ]
like it security is the sexiest thing i
cannot be with a guy who's insecure
about his [ __ ] yeah because we're taking
we're partners together if you found a
guy that's in his 20s and he's like
mature as [ __ ] you found a unicorn yeah
and that happens my brother's like that
he's yeah
but he came out of the womb like a
grumpy old man you know he came out
frowning yeah
he was like disgruntled
he's like my brother's more mature than
me but i like to say it like you're
going to like adopt a dog you have the
young dog who's like super cute
but like untrained untrained untrained
yeah and then you have the senior dog
who has his flaws but you know what
you're gonna get yeah yeah and he's
pre-trained like you don't have to yell
at him he's not gonna jump on your couch
like he like des has dated women that
have like he knows how to be a boyfriend
right right right and like you could try
to mold a dude but like honestly
i'm not a project manager i will forget
to send the email and then i'm [ __ ]
and like you don't know what the puppy's
gonna become yeah that's true he could
start liking crypto like you don't want
to deal
with him
with that [ __ ] these guys they [ __ ]
like discover a new thing because their
friend sent them a link
and then they lose 40 grand
i don't want to deal with that
yeah i mean we're gorgeous we're
actually saturday
we're stunning and all of our thoughts
are just italian
adopt me okay
no you have to drop that but the puppy
sent me treats
maybe we could do next time in new york
we should do like a youtube of like us
you guys and giggly squad us like doing
something fun together i'll throw up you
know that would be fun yeah like
somewhere maybe like we go to italian
restaurant and talk [ __ ] yes easy let's
break bread we're breaking let's start a
mafia oh yeah yeah yeah alexa
and anybody can come and have to be
italian sorry but like you can come in
we'll have like a little name yeah we
should dress like just like old mafia
gangster wives
[Music]
yeah we're doing it wait everyone kind
of looks the same in here all right
you're in the mafia with us not you
you're right you're a man you're a puppy
okay so before we wrap tell everyone
they can find your social media your
podcast oh my god comedy tickets
hannahbrunner.com b-e-r-n-e-r i have my
shows i'm gonna be in la in august doing
a stand-up show what day
i don't know in beginning and middle
regardless i'll let you know yes okay
and i'm going i'm going to portland i'm
going to um tacoma chicago okay madison
milwaukee so anyway if you guys have
i'll be in milwaukee yes hell yeah i'll
see you in milwaukee
and then you follow me on instagram and
tick tock and listen to giggly squad and
if you're into like mental health [ __ ]
mm-hmm my podcast burning in hell is
like a comedy mental health yes it's
really good kind of works obviously
thank you yeah two types of girls
i'm a giggler she's a burning
if you're emotionally ill listen to
burning in hell
i love it hannah i i loved you before
and i'm obsessed with you oh my god
thank you for having me thank you it was
honoring a privilege it was so much fun
we'll see you soon and we will see you
guys next tuesday bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you